we all have fond memories of the
playground hours upon hours spent in
Blissful childhood abandon racing around
the local park climbing the monkey bars
and seeing if you could get even higher
on the swings than your best friend and
then of course there's the slide who
doesn't love a slide only you and the
force of gravity pulling you down
through a straight or spiral tube those
few seconds of excitement that Rush of
not knowing whether you'll come out the
other end of the slide or not that's
enough of a thrill for any kid of course
you would always come tumbling out of
the mouth of the slide every time at
worst with an odd but innocent friction
burn on your leg or arm but what if one
day you didn't come out of the other end
or Worse what if the place at the end of
the slide wasn't the world you left
behind when you slid through the
entrance it doesn't seem all that likely
to happen right well you've obviously
never ever taken a trip down
scp-1562 better known as the tunnel
slide as its moniker suggests
scp-1562 is a slide or it at least
appears to be an ordinary tunnel slide
you know the kind that you would easily
find at any kids park jungle gym or
indoor play area just over 2 meters high
and almost three and a half meters long
and for the most part it is a completely
normal slide if you were to just sit in
it and glide down it feet first nothing
would happen then again if scp-1562 was
an ordinary everyday piece of a
playground then the SCP Foundation would
not have such a vested interest in it
they definitely wouldn't be keeping it
locked up in quarantine secured in
Testing Lab 46-v of site-24 and if any
foundation agents ask you didn't hear
that from us by the way the door to the
lab is kept locked at all times no
member of personnel is even allowed near
the slide unless granted special
clearance to do so by Foundation
researcher Dr Carver so what is it that
makes this thing so special well for one
scp-1562 was first recovered by the
foundation from a defunct abandoned
playground the location of this
playground has been redacted but it was
known to be on the outskirts of a town
where a number of young children had
been reported missing does scp-1562
contain some sort of clue as to where
these children were taken perhaps some
piece of forensic evidence left behind
by a child snatching anomaly From
Another Dimension not quite
scp-1562 is the thing that took those
children you see the slides anomalous
properties require very specific
circumstances in order to activate like
we mentioned earlier if you were just
sitting on your butt while you were
sliding down it you would Escape
unscathed laying flat on your back that
is also a safe option even flailing
yourself about spinning and rolling and
waving your arms changing position on
the way down would mean that nothing
anomalous would appear to happen however
if someone enters
scp-1562 and travels down in head first
laying on their stomach with their arms
tucked at their side almost in a plank
position then that is when strange
things start to happen that is when a
person finds out what happened to those
missing children only about 15
centimeters from the opening of the
slide a person sliding down on their
front head first With Arms by their
sides will disappear right before
exiting
scp-1562 in an instant they will simply
be gone no longer in the slide or even
relocated to anywhere nearby to make
matters worse every single person that
this has happened to has never been
found again they literally have vanished
off the face of the Earth unfortunately
there isn't much that can be done to
prevent this during testing the
foundation quickly learned that
tethering a safety line to a subject
does little to stop them from
disappearing they cannot be pulled back
from wherever it is that the slide sends
them the Rope they are attached to is
simply cut and goes slack from the
moment that a person is taken by the
slide now that sounds like the whole
story right children are going missing
and the foundation learns it's because
of
scp-1562 some kind of interdimensional
portal within a playground slide so they
acquire the slide take it away and keep
it locked up securely where it can't
cause any more disappearances end of
story except that's not quite the end no
the one thing it's still possible to do
once someone has disappeared on the
slide is to stay in contact with them
the SCP Foundation has expended a number
of test subjects by sending them sliding
down
scp-1562 just to learn what's on the
other side just where does the slide
take them luckily tests like the this
are precisely what the foundation has
d-class Personnel for so what happened
when the foundation sent some d-classes
on a one-way Joyride down the slide
while one test involved a d-class
designated
d2445 who disappeared into
scp-1562 but was given a two-way radio
to communicate directly with Dr daritz
one of the research staff
d-2445 reported that he felt himself in
a small cramped tunnel and quickly
requested to be let back out Dr derritz
had neglected to tell d2445 that was
impossible and that no one ever came
back from inside the slide while it was
too dark to see anything The Prisoner
described still being laid on his front
but feeling like there were rocks or
dirt surrounding him on all sides
realizing that he barely had enough room
to move or even lift his head
d2445 again requested to be let out of
scp-1562 as the unfortunate d-class grew
increasingly more unsettled by the
movement restricting environment Dr
deritz revealed that the lifeline
tethering d2445 back to the foundation
had been severed upon their
disappearance into the slide panicking
d-2445 managed to move forward slightly
and realized that his head had hit
something a shoe a tiny child's shoe
communication with d 2445 was called to
a halt and the foundation's researchers
discussed possible ways that they could
retrieve the prisoner although most of
them probably knew at this point that
this task was likely impossible this
test may have taken place before the
foundation realized that return from
scp-1562 was impossible the plan was
that another t-class would be sent into
the slide once again they would be
attached to a tether line and be
carrying video and audio recording
equipment along with the GPS tracker and
a headlamp reaching out to d-2445 Dr
derritz relayed this plan to him
d-2445 immediately begged to be set free
from SCP p1562 as the doctor attempted
to calm him down but too little a fact
something had scared him truly terrified
him a sound coming from somewhere within
the tunnel
it started talking
d-2445 claimed when Dr daritz asked for
clarity the d-class replied saying that
a little boy had tried to speak to him
but that the child had made little sense
he just kept asking where he was and I
told him I didn't know but I don't think
he was really talking to me because he
didn't respond to my voice and he told
me to stop crying when I was actually
sort of calm when asked if this child
had moved at all
d2445 said that he was unsure he started
screaming and I told him to shut up but
he just kept screaming and crying and
asking for his mommy and then he finally
stopped and shortly after that you've
contacted me again please get me out now
Dr deritz tried to reassure the man to
little Avail and communication with d
2445 was cut off after he claimed
something was wrong with his chest
shortly after the foundation lost
communication with d2445 another member
of d-class was sent into the slide after
him this subject referred to officially
ESD 8600 had been specifically selected
for this task thanks to his small
stature Dr derrets and the other
Foundation researchers testing
scp-1562 believed that the man's thinner
body type would allow d-8600 to better
navigate the tunnel that the slides
seemed to transport people to and you
can probably guessed what happened next
just like all the others that had been
sent down the slide D 8600 was trapped
his Lifeline was cut the moment that he
vanished inside the tunnel slide on top
of this the GPS tracker that this
thinner d-class had been issued with
seemed to not be working properly its
signal could not be correctly traced and
without an accurate fix there was no way
to determine the location to which
scp-1562 was transporting its victims if
it was even in this universe
Additionally the video feed from the
camera d8600 was carrying also failed to
connect with only audio from his radio
being recovered by the research team
contacting d8600 Dr Derricks was
informed by this new d-class that his
headlamped had stopped working the
second he had arrived in the same cave
or tunnel as earlier test subjects
before long by shimmying through the
area on his arms d8600 bumped into a
foot believed to be belonging to
d-2445 while he could barely see
anything d8600 could hear
d2445's voice and this was being faintly
picked up via His Radio however as he
and Dr daritz tried to talk to the first
prisoner his words began to sound all
too familiar I don't know some sort of
very small tunnel it's really cramped
can you get me out now followed by no
it's it's too dark I can't see anything
and I'm stuck it was all just a
recording from what d2445 had said when
he first arrived after
scp-1562 had sent him into the tunnel
d-8600 did not realize this at first and
attempted to help his fellow a prisoner
hoping to pull him out of wherever they
were trapped Dr deritz tried desperately
to explain the d-2445 was just repeating
his half of an earlier conversation but
D 8600 hardly noticed that was the case
he gripped the other d-class's ankles
and told the doctor to pull them out of
the tunnel the doctor revealed that once
again the tether line had been severed
but d8600 refused to believe that escape
was impossible he tried to worm his way
back the way he had come leaving d-2445
still repeating his words from earlier
he just kept asking me where he was and
I told him I didn't know but I don't
think he was really talking to me
because he didn't respond to my voice
and he told me to stop crying when I was
actually sort of calm I don't think so
he started screaming and I told him to
shut up but he kept just screaming and
crying and asking for his mommy then he
finally stopped and shortly after that
you contacted me again
please get me out now please hurry my
chest is really starting to hurt after
yelling at him to stop talking multiple
times D 8600 noted that d2445 had
finally gone quiet the d-class also
remarked that the air was starting to
taste stale and hope that there would be
enough oxygen for him to get back then
just like his predecessor communication
with d8600 came to an abrupt stop Dr
daritz was no longer able to reach him
on the radio there was nothing but
static the foundation was unable to
re-establish contact with either of the
two d-class Personnel lost inside
scp-1562 and any future testing of the
tunnel slide was suspended to this day
none of us know what exactly happened to
the victims of the tunnel slide where
were they taken what had taken them what
was making the prior victims repeat
their ominous words as horror author
Stephen King once put it it's the
unanswered questions that stays with us
the longest but the next time you decide
to Thrill your inner child by taking a
jean to your local Kitty Park you may
just find out for yourself now go check
out scp-3001 red reality and trapped in
a game
scp-1733 season opener for more
horrifying anomalous places you'd really
hate to be trapped inside